have a few things to say but also have a
few things to hear and interact on so
the broad plan here is to kind of let
the panel introduce themselves but we'll
go down through two passes here there's
lots of opportunity in the Broadband
Plan and in the five ideas that Eugene
put forward to look and hope for value
things that should be harvested the
upside potential of this and I want our
panel to sort of say some things they
see that they would hope for the high
value opportunities here but as with
anything that proposes to change the
world in our society or anybody's
society there are some risks and some
things that we would want to avoid in
the next kind of period of time in
trying to make this go forward so we
want to have a little time to talk about
that after we go through those things I
would like to hear some Q&A from the
audience and then we'll see if we've
come to some place we can make some
sense out of it so panelists go down
just introduce yourselves in the first
pass through Chris sure I've already
deduced myself Chris you're suddenly hi
director of the Center for future civic
media here at MIT I am the GUP -
evangelist o'reilly media my name is
john Wonderlic I'm the policy director
at the sunlight foundation and I'm Nick
Grossman I'm the director of civic works
at the open planning project so we now
not only have a Broadband Plan we have
an administration that on its first day
and a president who put out ideas that
said this stuff will be more important
at this time and in this administration
than before what do we see looking at
that and listening to Eugene's ideas as
the upside potential things we ought to
be sure and grab a hold of here Chris
sure you know our work has been focusing
on one of the interesting things about
the history of the Internet is that it's
it's done incredible work for empowering
affinity groups online groups people who
share interests but it's been less much
less clear how it helps individual
communities actually geographic
communities which are the kinds of
locations that law happens and the kinds
of locations that people can't get out
of their neighborhoods they they have a
civic obligation of
and and you know part of the reason is
because of this huge issue of digital
divide which happens across ages across
Khomeini's so one of the great
opportunities that we're seeing is the
opportunity to start thinking about what
are the software platforms that a
community can use not just at the
federal level which there's been a lot
of attention on recently but at the at
the local level at the you know the
alderman or the county level and so
among the experiments that we've been
running at the center have been trying
to understand how community collective
action can happen differently online
what are the ways that people can
organize apart from just gathering news
and understanding news how can they use
that news to change their communities
we've been looking at how communities
can understand their own financial
situation better so some of our students
are leveraging on the popularity of
sites like Minter Expensify that allow
people to aggregate their their
financial information so that a
community can understand where money is
going out of the community
you know what are the kinds of services
that they're paying outside and losing
money on and and preventing themselves
from empower economically empowering
themselves and the last one I'll just
mention is you know thinking about new
tools and techniques for deliberative
decision making and and and and and
agenda building and we think that those
are potentially really powerful just
just as a quick idea on the community
focus is it mostly that we are expanding
penetration of online possibilities or
is the broadband and the speed and
broadband particularly important for the
community focus you're talking about
well I think it is particularly
important because if you look at a lot
of these technologies they've really
been primarily used by you know 20 some
things on you know in in San Francisco
New York and and you know what what
you're seeing is that demographic builds
especially with hopefully the broadband
initiatives emphasis on on inclusion
then what you're going to see is that a
lot of different people are going to be
using these tools and so it can more
holistically represent the society
whereas right now it's doing a great job
of representing you know just relatively
small parts of society Laurel I think
major points that Eugene really made was
that broadband is not going to be used
just for video games
loading pirated music and videos and
you're just playing around in the
Internet we're talking about serious
work being done not just in communities
and government but also entrepreneurs
and the technologists that are needed to
kind of put this vision into action
we're moving away from the social web
where we vote on Facebook for our
favorite things and sign petitions that
are really silly and moving also to the
civic web and that is taking this extra
energy and looking at our individual
local communities which we all sort of
have a real tie to that's where we pay
taxes that's where we live that's we
wait for the bus and go to work and how
can we actually transform that to a
reality which is the digital natives
that work until 7 o'clock at night don't
get home in time to go to public
meetings but still need to be able to
participate online and well in some
fashion in that fashion is now online so
the importance of just transparency
including video and having city hall
meetings on video and online available
later for public comment is really
critical and documenting how communities
grow and change over the years will be
very important so that was very
heartening to hear also just the
importance of recognizing that
technology is already there and
enterprise and private communities are
actually using these tools and
techniques and the government sort of
needs to hurry up and play catch-up so
everyone can participate let me a small
follow-up on that in the sense that
community again is a central value
historically local communities were more
powerful probably than they are today in
that sense that when I grew up you knew
all your neighbors and now you don't you
see this communication capacity through
broadband re strengthening or
strengthened in a new way the very local
communities that's really important
absolutely I probably know more of my
neighbors online through our yahoo email
group list than I've ever met in person
and when you have an initiative in your
local community and you want to gather
as many people as you can both first
thing you things that you
Jews create a Facebook group right or
some other online platform and then you
when it gains momentum and steam then
you go out with a paper initiative you
try to get signatures and you knock on
doors people who you don't actually know
and so this is sort of a problem you
know getting back to our neighborhoods
and the neighborhood as a platform is
really critical because you're looking
at the space where you spend a lot of
time you want to invest this is where
you're raising your children where
you're where you're working and you need
it to be the best community that it can
be and so what you know we're asking is
that with technology it can be it but it
is also very very careful balance of
people and training and understanding
that technology does not replace people
but actually makes especially in small
governments where every single dollar so
precious these days it can make just
everyone's time be used more efficiently
so I would say that a civic engagement
through digital technology like the
broadband that we're discussing today
certainly has an impact locally and also
we are starting to see at the sunlight
foundation in our work abroad systemic
effect across society so the the rush of
and flourishing new information that's
coming out as a result of the
administration's open government
directive is being replicated or perhaps
was already happening on a congressional
level and across many states that are
undertaking similar initiatives to
release information and that kind of
information access is the thing that is
empowering all of us to be better
researchers or to be lobbyists or to be
investigative reporters or Civic
journalists so everyone is being
empowered in the same sense in which
only certain few people used to be
empowered and just one particular
example there's a bill in a hearing in
the Merritt Maryland State House today
actually that's going to do a lot of
things but one of the things that it's
doing is taking access to real-time
information about legislation that used
to cost eight hundred dollars a year if
you wanted to access it you had to pay a
once a year subscription fee of
something like eight hundred dollars and
they're gonna do away with that
subscription fee and replace it with a a
fee for for people that want to register
as lobbyists and that's the sort of
redistribution of power that we think is
really empowering especially because of
the other change that we're seeing which
is in the platforms and tools that
people have access to that are changing
the way that we analyze and share and
look and look at information and that
doesn't just go for people who have
access to broadband I think people who
have access only through newspapers or
only through television benefit also
from from better transparency and
digital access because of the people
that are writing those newspaper stories
or the people that the producers that
CNN are also using the Internet to get
their information so the effects are
pretty broad so you see an opportunity
that many people could get energized to
participate partly because the barrier
to entry is a lot lower if you've got a
lot of information in tools readily
accessible and you don't have to devote
an entire evening to stopping what
you're doing and going to participate
and you see then that this engagement
should not only be thought of as
communities and locally but it will
really spread in many many ways and we
should seek that yeah different levels
of government and also you know for some
important stories to be told you needed
a computer-assisted reporter who knew
someone who can make a good chart who
knew someone who who was a reporter and
suddenly that those might all be the
same person so some of the stories that
we need to be told I think are much more
likely to be told now okay so the thing
that I think is exciting is that
government services are potentially a
gateway drug to civic engagement and
it's not necessarily about jumping right
into debating policy with your neighbors
but it's that broadband mobile access
has made it easier for people to use
their cities and once they start having
a better connection with the day to day
services that they use they can step
into a more substantive conversation
with the people who are making all that
happen so for example you know I ride
the bus to work and I can see on my
iPhone when the next bus is coming
that's great information with me gets me
a little bit more connected with who's
providing that service and it's really
easy to take the next step and then slip
in a little bit of feedback into that
and so all of a sudden now I'm having a
conversation with those
well and Laurel mentioned the idea of
the Civic web I think that's a really
nice way to describe it it's not just
about politics and government it's about
the whole city and our whole community
and how we use it so I think that's
really exciting so it truly is the
interactivity that's possible things
aren't just from the institution to the
individual that many more ways are going
to open up for some feedback for some
engagement in that yeah and government
is intimidating for people so if you
start with the things that are already
easy to to use and then are just part of
your the things you need to get done in
the in your in your day to day that's
really a way to get started they I think
it's called a delicious effect so the
Dilek bookmark tagging website people
use it because I wanted to save their
own bookmarks but then there was a
secondary Network effect that benefited
the rest of people and I think there's a
lot of opportunity for a similar
approach in civic applications where you
make something that's useful for someone
to do the thing that they need to do but
then it has benefits for everyone else
okay so we've gone through and we've
sort of laid the table out with some of
the things we would hope to see happen
here and the potential that's been given
to us like any change there's some risks
and some things we would perhaps want to
avoid and not fall into what do you see
is those crisps well like most when you
go to the dentist they tend to
concentrate on the bad teeth and my list
for negatives is longer I guess the
first one I think has to do with
sloppiness I think that you know the
amount of data that's available is
growing but but people's understanding
even fairly sophisticated people's
understanding of it isn't necessarily
growing and and that's the kind of a
national kind of expertise that we're
going to have to build so I'll give an
example of there's this whole rash of
crime mapping applications that are out
that basically use reports from police
departments which is great except that
you know I have yet to find one that
actually does white-collar crime you
know which case Manhattan would just be
this big red kind of blur you know and
and and Westchester County and a bunch
of so-so but you know the the the trick
there are you actually offering
information
are you offering really facile
statistics that look more like redlining
than they do like actually informing a
user empowering them so so I think that
that kind of ignorance is I think one of
the top problems next I say that while
we're seeing this this potentially
incredible movement towards citizen
journalism and towards citizen generated
information and we're not necessarily
seeing the same legal protections or
norms that protected journalists or
journalism organizations in the past I
think this is a huge issue that needs to
be taken head-on and thought very
carefully of when I gave the example of
what George Washington providing
discounts postal discounts for
newspapers and magazines the estimated
cost in today's dollars of that is it
was something like two billion dollars a
year you know that this Broadband Plan
is covering 7.2 billion so so that was a
constant renewing advantage that was
given to small small operators so that
their voice could be heard part of that
is that net neutrality is a huge key we
could have national broadband and things
could go south very very quickly in
terms of what kind of speech people are
allowed to have on that broadband some
of our best allies in the United States
like South Korea you have to enter a
real government ID number in order to
leave a comment on a blog and bloggers
are being arrested for reporting
anti-government or actually true stories
that the government doesn't want them to
publish that's not a feature that we
want and so a corollary that is that
anonymous speech should be guaranteed
you know not every site has to use
anonymous speech I would much rather run
a blog comment section where people had
to log in and be consistent but but
let's not forget that the Federalist
Papers many of the key Enlightenment
texts that this country was founded on
were done anonymously because the
authors felt that it was judicious and
you know when Hillary Clinton says as
she did recently we must also grapple
with the issue of anonymous speech one
of my students said no we must also
protect that right as vitally as we can
afford democracy grapple is the wrong
word so so you know I think these are
some of the the the the largest concerns
that I have
you know I think Clay Shirky once said
the problem with the situation with the
old media losing losing most of their
business model before something has
filled its place is that you know that's
what happens in a time of transition the
old things break before the new things
take their place and I think that's
where we are right now we need a lot of
advocacy and a lot of laws to kind of
protect the coming situation in what
we've seen so far for the things that
we're positive we've seen some specific
recommendations made of things to be
done
do you see enough energy in the process
that's going forward now to address the
concerns that you've just had about
protecting the small voices and also
trying to do something about eliminating
the downside risks of clear ignorant
yeah you know I would say that I'm
seeing the opposite energy that some of
these international traits and and trade
agreements and attempts to create legal
regime around copyright and theft are
what could potentially kill any of the
positive things that we've just been
talking about so you know that that to
me is a huge concern because a variety
of you know fairly small businesses have
gathered together to try to protect
their rights in a way that could erode
the greater rights of this potential
information revolution so Laura one of
the things I think that needs to be
avoided is that open government isn't
just for a closed smartphone device that
we need to actually build web
applications and applications in general
for every kind of device whether it's a
phone or computer or also maybe a sensor
that's left at your bus stop so you no
longer need to have pieces of paper that
tell you what time the bus comes but
something that you can actually go up
and just push a button and it'll tell
you so then we're lowering the divide so
it's not an entry point of a $500
computer 400 or smartphone or even $150
cable bill when government thinks about
making themselves open yeah you know
encouraging and engaging in these the
sensor technology is also really
important as well because we want to
bridge that digital digital divide as
quickly and as completely as possible
another thing is that procurement is
pretty tricky of course these days and
I'm curious to see how the bidding would
go for video gov
contract when we saw data gov go up for
bid like that quotes came back at eighty
million dollars for a website which just
made us all all nice work if you can get
it it's nice work if you can get it so
web developers out there yes you you
will have a secure future and also a web
app does not make a movement just
because a city gives you data to one
section does not mean the city has
complete and total buy-in of all of
their data we're looking at holistic
views of how we can open data across
municipalities across states and in the
federal government as well the hope is
is that we need to make these changes
correctly and completely but then also
make them so they stand in place when
the White House buys into something like
transparency and open data this is a
clear sign for all the other municipal
governments to also kind of chime in and
say well if the White House is doing it
we too should do it that's good but when
politics change and administration's
change we're talking about long term
good for the people for citizens and not
just for the politicians in their short
terms one of the things you started with
was the concern again about we need to
close the digital divide we need to be
more inclusive
do you see broadband itself as
emphasizing a speaking mode that's
traditional for everybody not so much
just writing but as therefore a more
natural way to include larger numbers of
people well it's a learning curve like
everything else we were out in Montana a
couple years ago and we're waiting in
line with everyone else at the library
to get access to email and we're just
trying to get access to email we're
trying to get access to apply for a job
or any kind of government plants or
anything we were just on vacation and I
looked at this like this is crazy in
Boston where we come from there's Wi-Fi
in every corner and everyone has a
computer so if you really needed access
to always borrow someone's but we're
talking about educating large amounts of
the population to not just use
technology but to use it well and to use
it for the greater good so I think the
digital divide has to come hand in hand
with some real you know human training
as well it's not just the technology so
start at the chores start the libraries
the local governments and you know get
the library some more funding again so
they can be open on Saturdays when
people traditionally have the day off
and start these classes in communities
so people realize that to them using a
keyboard may be foreign but after a
while once they receive feedback and
understand that this is the way that
that society is now communicating don't
feel more comfortable about it good John
a couple of risks or pitfalls to
identify first I think we need to have a
careful balance between on one side when
we're making them more open or more
participatory government or civic sphere
there's encouragement and
experimentation so this sort of please
do it model it'll be good for you and
then on the other side there's statutory
requirements or codified requirements so
with the administration's open
government directive that's a bit of a
combination of both right now I would
say it's a little bit more on the
encouragement side since it doesn't have
me hard-and-fast requirements but I
would also say that that that's
appropriate so when you're dealing with
something where that where best
practices are as unclear as they are for
digital participation right now I think
it's a careful thing to balance when you
should pass a law requiring something or
when you should have issue guidelines
recommending or encouraging some kind of
behavior second just like in the same
way as some of our business models are
outdated I think some of our cultural
expectations about openness are outdated
just two examples one if you look back
to president then senator or candidate
Obama's promises around health care
deliberations I think the whole country
is in a very different place than we
were a year ago when that promise flew
and he said that it would all be on
c-span and I think part of that is
because what we went through of a part
of that is also because we're growing
new expectations about what it means to
have deliberations in public and that
that's going to be a complex process for
everyone to go through I think the same
is true when you talk about accuracy of
data when you look at recovery gov when
that when that went up there are all
these news stories saying oh we got you
you bought 2 million
of ham for $5.00 or whatever it was it
turned out that that was just an error
and how in how the data was described so
we have different expectations about
what the point is of putting out this
site and and what data it data accuracy
should be so those are just two examples
of places where we need to grow better
cultural expectations and understandings
about what to expect it's been very
interesting to be over the many years as
the toxics release inventory has been
released
how many debates took place about the
adequacy of that data which was
considered to be really lousy data but
it's been interesting to see how people
have adjusted and the evolution of that
has taken place over time Nick I'd say
as as more governments get on on board
with doing open government and broadband
brings back to more people I think a big
risk is that governments will try and do
too much themselves and that means
trying to build too many tools that
could be better built by say the private
sector and the other risk is that they
could move too slowly and get stuck in
old ways of doing things in both cases
you're talking about broadband and
pakodas computing as a disruptive
innovation and there's a poster of
Clayton Christensen out front talking
about how that how that affects
industries and one of the things that in
both cases you need to look at is the
new entrance into providing services who
are going to be innovating faster and
trying out new approaches and doing less
and doing things you know with a whole
new approach then you would have done
even a year ago so if government doesn't
is tries to move to incrementally they
run the risk of totally missing the boat
and and spending too much money
providing something that doesn't work
well enough so you've seen in a lot of a
lot of effort in the open government
space right now to focus on opening up
data so that application developers can
start building consumer tools that's
been a really positive model and but
it's a real mind shift for government
agencies to get away from we need to
build every single piece of the entire
experience - we can focus on doing the
thing that we can do really well which
is often providing the data providing a
platform and
thing other people build interfaces on
top of that but if you degree in
non-exclusive ways because every one of
the things we're seeing is that in the
1990s and early 2000s government entered
a lot of relationships exclusive
relationships with a single vendor
definitely and that's why we're in this
mess right and that's why we advocate
for open data at all points of the
process so if you're say you're
releasing transit data which is
something we work on a lot you don't
want to get into a private data sharing
arrangement with one vendor like New
York City has with Google for a long
time you want to have an open interface
using open standards so that anybody can
build anything on top of that data and
as I hear this of a government that can
make mistakes either going to slow or
locked-in to incrementally or trying to
do too much too fast do you think that
the current plans as you understand them
are more or less in the right position
or is the danger more one or the other
the current plans for open government
and the current plan plans for broadband
certainly for broadband in the
conjunction of civic interaction and
open government well okay so you saw on
with what you were getting out in terms
of incentives versus requirements is
that if you build too many requirements
you end up potentially getting data that
an information that's not useful and so
the incentives have to be structured so
that people are building the interests
are aligned between people who are using
the data and people who are providing it
so that you don't end up spending a lot
of money providing data or anything else
that's not actually useful and I think
you run the same risk trying to if you
mandate too much open government
interface where interface is the actual
end user software I think there's a
potential for a lot of money and effort
to be spent making something that's not
good and doesn't provide a good
experience and people don't use and then
it'll be seen as a failure in a waste
okay so we've laid out a few things very
very quickly on what we might be hoping
for and what we might be worried about
as this goes forward and we're open for
Q&A to see and hear what you folks I
think we ought to talk about to make
sense of what is a very big announcement
of a very big program at a very
important time so
yes good idea good evening my name is
Nolan Bui I'm a colleague of Gerry's I
teach at the Kennedy School I had a
question for Eugene I noticed that among
the five core goals of the plan there
was no mention that closing the digital
divide particularly within a set
timeframe was among those and in regards
to the first goal of having a open and
transparent government where all of the
public information to govern if
information is available on-line wealth
citizens will investigative reporters
will public interest organizations and
advocates and attorneys still have to
file a Freedom of Information Act to get
information or will it all be available
and if so how will we know what is
missing in regards to the panel at large
and in regard to the digital divide if
we began to sort of try to empower all
of the communities when then do we get
to closing the digital divide and at the
same time by empowering those
communities who are already empowered
don't we increase the gaps don't we
ultimately need a timetable both great
questions take them in order first
question about bridging the adoption gap
the recommendations that I discussed
today cover one very small area of the
National Broadband Plan which is the
portion related to civic engagement
broadly the National Broadband Plan is
broke
into three main groups the first group
deals with broadband deployment the
infrastructure question how do we get
infrastructure out there and right now
we believe that about 95 percent of
Americans have access to broadband
infrastructure chairman Genachowski
chairman of the FCC about a week week
and a half ago indicated a goal of 100
squared which is making sure that we
have 100 megabit access to 100 million
homes in America within 10 years so
that's one issue second issue the issue
that you addressed which is broadband
adoption and and the gap last week the
FCC released a survey which indicated
that between 65% to 70% of Americans
have American have who have access to
broadband or currently subscribed to
broadband services which means that
there's a gap of about 30 to 35% of
Americans that don't have access what
what was important about that survey was
that it was the first survey of that non
adopter group and you know many
individuals have and many groups have
gone out and said that 30 to 35 percent
Americans don't have access but have
never told us much about that group at
all
I'll give you one example the as you can
imagine some of the non-adopters include
individuals over 65 as well as the poor
and the FCC is hosting a event at the
Museum on I believe March 9th to roll
out the recommendations related to
adoption and closing the gap but one
example here that is instructive in
certain cases we realize that broadband
is either too expensive for individuals
which is one of the reasons that were
cited or is not relevant to people's
lives and so we had the CEO of Skype
come visit us they indicated that the
fastest-growing group
of adopters for skype services or
individuals aged 55 and over the reason
why they they see they they use skypes
web video conferencing service to see
pictures of new port of their newborn
grandkids and so the first thing that
happens is they call up their son or
daughter and say I want a computer and I
want broadband access to see continue to
see pictures of my grandkids and so that
demonstrates that you know there's
partially relevance that's partially you
know there's a whole host of reasons why
the gap is this and the FCC will be
rolling out recommendations next week to
address some of the the gap issues on
the second question about FOIA what we
recognize is that all of these tools do
not replace FOIA and we recognize that
FOIA potentially is the oldest version
of open government open government
initiatives that have been historically
going on in administrations for some
time this will not replace for you but
what we realize is that by providing
data providing tools that these tools
will help empower Americans help empower
the individual citizen to learn about
their government know more about their
government hold their government
accountable and gain access to
government services bridging the digital
divide as much as a $400 computer is not
always affordable to everybody it still
is a $400 computer compared to either
just two or three four years ago we are
talking much much greater money for a
device to get you online so in an ideal
world it would be nice if there were
some school you know every school kid
had a computer or at least access to one
so within my realm of expertise that's
what I would like to see but also as far
as and businesses just simple businesses
trying to get information and open data
you can imagine and this actually does
happen in Chicago a coffee shop who
purchases an LED sign for say $100 and
this project is actually also happened
MIT Media Lab and a stream of open data
from say the MBTA the transit system and
in Boston comes to you and lets you know
how far away the next bus is for the bus
stop right outside your coffee shop so
then you put up the sign for small
investment and your customers can see
how long it takes for another cup of
coffee you know between the buses and so
then you're spurring entrepreneur
intrapreneurship as well as enterprise
because that for that small investment
that coffee shop owner does not have to
be online doesn't have to know anything
about broadband or being online at all
but they do have a device that gives
their customers something that otherwise
you know they would just be waiting
outside the bus stop waiting for the bus
to come so I mean there are some lower
barriers to entry on some of these
devices we're starting to see again as
costs come down for production and
manufacturing we'll see much more
Eugene's point quickly about moving
beyond FOIA which in order to talk
seriously about I think you need to talk
three or five decades from now in order
to ever get beyond the model citizens
affirmatively requesting things but in
the meantime there's a huge gap between
on one side what agencies are required
by law to disclose and those things that
they choose to disclose because it's in
their interest and to us I think most
people they recognize that between those
two things there's a whole world of
things that agencies should be thinking
about releasing that may be in
everyone's interest but maybe they
wouldn't choose to release voluntarily
that initiatives like the open
government directive and other forces at
work now are going to have benefits for
everyone that aren't necessarily things
they would they're required by law or
that they would choose voluntarily to
release
another question I had two unrelated two
questions one on a digital divide and
the other on open source it's fairly
well-established that people who have
lower income and perhaps lower reading
literacy even are not using computers
but they own cell phones many many of
them do about 50% of those not using the
internet and I'm wondering what whether
the government the FCC in particular in
this broadband initiative is taking any
of that into account in its planning
including how you present the content so
that it's accessible you know on a
screen with small real estate and the
usual interface problems on the open
source side I'm very interested if the
government's really trying to have an
open source policy and pursuing open
source software because it takes a huge
effort to get over that inertia okay now
that question I actually we may pull you
if it's legal to do so Eugene into some
more of these conversations because some
of them address more what the FCC is
directly doing as opposed to our
observations on it but panel do you yeah
I'll start with the open source question
that's something my organization deals
with every day and many and that we were
working mostly on the local level many
cities are now adopting formal
open-source policies and we're
cataloging them at a website that we run
called open Muni org if you go there you
can see them there's a wiki and we're
trying to help cities learn from one
another open sourcing open source policy
San Francisco is a really good example
they just created a open-source
procurement policy and the CIO then said
yes I'm getting lots of flack for my
vendors so this is a open source is
absolutely integral to the open data
open government movement open source is
a way of building software to be
shareable and contributor well so other
people can contribute to it and make it
something different so the whole point
is to write an application once and use
it many times and also it is free so
that is usually one of the the good
aspects of it but not always so the
white house also built website on Drupal
which is an open source content
management solution so we are seeing
quite a bit of adoption and a lot of
people beating the open-source drum
which is very good ok actually let me
make one quick comment about the
cellphone concept in 1987 we started a
program at the Kennedy School that was
looking at what we first called
strategic computing and then it was
leadership in a networked world but the
interesting thing to us as a huge focus
of attention has been tensions between
political people and technology people
in government and could they find a
common agenda the common agenda became
the phrase online not in line 24 by 7
the fact that you could deliver services
without having to change too much of the
government to people who appreciated it
and therefore people who talk to the
public and had to show them some result
from a public action had something to
point to that people really did
appreciate with cell phones becoming
such a big connective device to the
internet I expect that lots of
governments will be putting very serious
attention into how it can reach you know
getting back to my dentist role I spot a
cavity because I mean an you know David
read one of my colleagues at MIT who
developed enten protocol in the internet
really really smart guy he said if I as
an engineer was
to devise a you know like an information
system that would be perfect for robert
mugabe it would be the american phone
system as it stands now and so you know
unfortunately yeah governments are
paying a lot of attention to this
they're shutting down the phone system
in countries after elections that don't
go though government wants them to so
it's an incredibly potentially
transformative technology but it's also
right now an incredibly dangerous one
because there is no potential freedom of
speech it's it's almost entirely done
through private interests and when
governments want to get involved as we
saw domestically in the NSA wiretapping
scandal they can do that and so you know
I think this is it's a very dangerous
path to say that while phones are an
excellent way for people to access
information they're also an incredibly
successful way to control information
and to prevent people from being able to
act on it so but you would like the city
of Cambridge to offer such services I I
would like to see phone technologies
that don't use service providers
necessarily and and there are
peer-to-peer systems that allow that you
know if you math has shown that
peer-to-peer phones can actually have
significantly better bandwidth and
emergency situations the more people
with phones the more bandwidth you get
and there are some phone manufacturers I
won't mention them but they work in
Finland who are working actively on this
much to the chagrin of some of the major
providers which is that people talk a
lot about mobile when they talk about
the digital divide but I think we also
have a participate or what I'm gonna
call a part an analog participation
divide so in the existing forums that we
have for community input there's a
greater divide than the digital divide
and I think there was a report that you
published on your website that was the
digital town halls study that showed
that you know you bring an analog
process online and the people who'd use
the online version tend to be more more
diverse from more different incomes more
different backgrounds so I think there's
a possibility to address issues of
participation divided without even
talking about the digital divide that
we're talking about
oh yeah library hi Chris mark tamozawa
from civic express which is not even a
thing it's just a network of people who
work across academia private and public
industry and nonprofits and education
including first responders Chris thank
you for the Haiti stuff of three or four
weeks ago that full week that you
launched I thought that was a marvelous
example of some of this the value of
smart people coming together using a
public platform and helping to
reconstruct an entire society we say
open source but I think that's an
example of open resource I think the
government sometimes could get capture
immense value not just from the people
who Chris and Dale had in the room
working with the State Department but if
you open that up to the citizens and you
say we need information that's not in a
federal database what can you tell us
about this situation in your
neighborhood can you share photos can
you share stories are there retirees who
used to work for medicine the State
Department academia public health I
think that would be marvelous to have
open resource as a comeback channel and
building on laurels bus-stop analogy
what if instead of stopping to buy a cup
of coffee you put in some information
and you help save taxpayers a billion
dollars now I use that big number for
reason I talked to Governor Rendell I
said what if we could have teams virtual
teams work on saving people money and
time would you pay them if they hit a
metric and he said absolutely and I said
why he said I pay them in year one and
after that I wouldn't pay them we just
lower taxes so I'd like to know if there
is a chance to recapture knowledge from
everybody in the United States for
starters around very specific issues
that government finds overwhelming
because they become clogs and
bottlenecks and if we can use former NSA
people to work with current NSA people
right if we can open up the informal
network the mesh and complement the
formal institutions that somehow become
overwhelmed when things are moving very
very quickly
I wanted to ask if that was part of the
plan or if it could be part of the plan
and the other thing I wanted to say was
there are a lot of kids who can make
this stuff dance and a lot of them are
in high school if we had a public
initiative and said we need to make
every cell phone attached in a Civic way
to a Civic location where the government
says we're working on this we need your
help
and we actually rewarded prizes for good
thinking I think you would unleash
massive massive creativity it's all
there I just think somehow we've set up
rules sometimes that hold kids back so
I'd like to say this could become our
version of the 1960s where it's not
Rosie the Riveter it's like we're all in
the pool and no one has helped me to
understand that I just don't know if
this is something government welcomes
it's gonna happen the trajectory of all
this is inevitable like Ushahidi so the
question is is there a role for an
individual and a group of individuals to
work with the FCC help say here are
specific possibilities that are ready to
go that's ultimately my question
panelists hmm so I hate to respond to
such a an optimistic question with a
with a pitfall but there is a statutory
prohibition on the government accepting
volunteer help which is kind of
ridiculous if you look at it from this
context but if you look at it from the
context of of the the budget shutdown in
the 90s or other similar things you can
see the spirit in which such a law was
passed so it needs to be an outside
organization working with the government
in parallel and a sibling relation or
when people come up with such ideas
there are certain entities within the
government that have gift authority that
are allowed to accept gifts so then you
just channel it through there for
example that that's one of the one of
the things that we route around is this
this kind of old-world idea about not
being able to accept help because it
would be it could create corruption here
we're just talking about what should be
fundamental to democracy giving things
away for free like ideas right exactly
which we would not we
we wouldn't want because yes because
then you'd feel beholden I think there's
a lot of enthusiasm within government
for this kind of project but that sort
of broad scale idea that you're talking
about is difficult to plan well and so
we're at an earlier stage and we're
starting to see things like Carl Malamud
in the last few weeks and now it's
something called the in I think it's
called the International amateur
scanners league and it's an email list
with 10 or 15 people on it that are
starting to go to the National Archives
and they're showing up with DVDs and
making DVD copies of videos that the
National Archives has they email them to
Carl who then puts it on YouTube and
makes a permanent digitized copy of it
and that's that's or so that's one thing
the world of digitization that could be
crowd-sourced there's also resource
collections so when you think about
policy work you say there are high-risk
things you can do with the public but
then there are also much lower risk
things like what are the best examples
of this or what are the best resources
we should rely on as we think through
this and that's certainly something that
the FCC has done as they came about this
plan but for the bigger ideas like the
ones that you're talking about that's
that's something that I hope we're gonna
see a lot more of in the coming years
and I you could see it in the coming
months actually referring to crawl
Carl's work is is good because I mean
Carl's taking this approach that it's
better to you know ask forgiveness than
beg permission and you know some of some
of that work happens like all politics
happens is essentially leveraging from
the outside and so some of it is
cooperation but it's cooperation that
only works with some of the members of
government who are really happy about it
and helping that you to push the other
members of government who are I'm
waiting to see what happens at the
midterm election my real question is can
someone address or kick around the idea
of the dissolution with the government
that's happening there is some buzz that
maybe Scott Brown was elected because of
that I think more that will show up at
midterm elections that's interesting
talk about voter participation with this
technology but we're talking about a
country that compared to other countries
actually has low participation and
it's probably going lower actually so
can somebody kick around the
disillusionment with government in the
first place do people really want to use
it engagement in its relationship to a
situation now where a lot of people are
angry and disillusioned with government
I don't think they'll ever be a time
when people are not angry and
disillusioned of government so sure then
we need to pounce on this moment and see
it as a really great time to recreate
the government what does what is the
government what is what is it that we
want it to be this is not what it is
everyone is angry doesn't matter what
side of the aisle you're on so I think
this is a fantastic time to start
thinking about these issues actually
doing something and kind of stop talking
about it I think this goes back to my
original idea that one of the things
that technology can help government
offer people are the answers to their
basic needs and if we start doing that
well that sort of builds confidence back
there's an opportunity on the basic
services level and our generation or the
next generation or all of us are going
to expect government to work like
Facebook or Amazon or Google and to the
extent that it starts doing that I think
it will make people happy I'm a small
stuff something I've been interested in
for a long period of time and have tried
not to take personally when I graduated
from graduate school I went into
government and I know that the Gallup
people were taking polls then that
they've taken forever
which is asking people at what rate does
your government do the right thing and
the four points were almost never you
know some of the time most of the time
almost always and when I came out most
of the time was what most of the people
said it was more than 80% and it has
pretty persistently gone downhill and
down the hill and down hill and down the
hill and down the hill and it bumps up
occasionally but we have lost a great
deal of trust in government and that's
happened around the globe one of the
interesting things to me about this is
directly addressing the
parentsí issue will Trust improve if the
government explicitly shows we are doing
a lot to not allow you to think we're
hiding things from you and I'm not sure
it'll work but I am pretty sure it's an
important problem and legitimacy is a
very critical problem and so I'm happy
that we're working on it and I think
there's a plausible story that it could
be powerful but the proof is in many
puddings and we've got to see what
happens I'm a fellow bus rider and I'm
delighted to hear that it's this issues
rising to the surface and even more
hopeful that when I push the button that
tells me when the next bus is coming it
might even be based on GPS and tell me
if it's 20 minutes late so my question
is once we've resolved all of the
relationship engagement issues and the
infrastructure what plans are there
involved for sustainability and making
sure that when I push that button it
actually works and and wondering if that
would come out of the 7 billion dollars
that's a good point I mean
sustainability of any kind of government
initiative is really quite critical but
whether it is a website that you expect
to find in the next administration like
Dena gov it'll be interesting is that
anyone could just turn on decide to not
do this anymore and just turn off data
gov or turn off of whatever gov so I
think it's a matter of making sure that
it's clear that those things are
tremendously useful as for the bus thing
in particular I mean I think it's
important for governments to be able to
try and find sustainable funding models
for for all different kinds of services
and to approach projects in a way that
are less capital intensive so the bus
example specifically we advocate for for
agencies to put out the data first and
then build a hard infrastructure so once
the data feed is out there then you work
with the the shop owners to get the
ad-supported when's the next bus coming
signs and those pay for themselves and
then you start rolling out the signs and
so you're not saddled with a big
infrastructure cost at the at the
beginning of a project so there are
creative ways to fund things if you if
you rethink the order of operations
that's that's a great example because
actually all the buses in Boston have
GPS units on them already the data just
was in public and so by going if you if
you actually ask the government to
design a sign it take cost about 50
thousand dollars for them to make sure
that it's this is a term of art sailor
proof
meaning that someone's swinging on it or
or pelting bottles at it won't destroy
it whereas if you ask private entities
to host of sign in their shop they're
you know it's on private property
there's a whole different set of laws
regarding that and you know most chopped
owners will just put it in the window
and assume that no one will try to throw
things at it so so really kind of
different regime also of how much cost
to do each sign and to develop each sign
and I think that that's where some of
the creativity and understanding what
private public partnerships can happen
you know and also basically how to
leverage the government to give up data
there's a great project called every
block they came out a couple years ago
that produces all sorts of machine
readable data on communities and it was
a five-person programming team one of
whom wasn't actually doing any software
programming their job was to go from
municipality to municipality getting
concessions on what kind of data the
local government would give up and when
Boston gave up say liquor licenses and
would start putting that out in XML that
person would then get on a plane to like
Chicago in Atlanta and say well you know
Boston's pretty high-tech they've put
out liquor licenses on XML and Chicago
would be like we'll put out liquor
licenses and we'll even put out you know
movie shoot locations and you know and
so basically one person's job was to go
from place to place to place forcing
these concessions so I mean you know
it's really exciting how much data is
out there that can simply just be opened
by someone deciding that that's going to
be the policy okay we're going to let
our panel have a few concluding words
but I think we've hit squeeze in one
more quick question
if it's quick
I guess so far I've heard the engagement
used interchangeably with access that
most of this talk has been gone towards
government transparency rather than
necessarily public participation and I
wondered if you could talk about the
potential for technology to move from or
to move from representational government
to more direct participation in the
process of governing by the public I'm
wondering if sort of this technology is
going to lead to a blurring of the
institutional boundaries between public
and private action or if this is more
about just replacing brick walls with
glass panel yeah I heard someone once
described the the downside of
transparency as glare right you know so
if you if you really want people to not
know what's doing you dump as many
documents as possible and they won't be
able to figure it out for a while but
but fighting against that is you know
news organizations young news
organizations like Talking Points Memo
which dumps 50 thousand pages of
documents and within a couple of hours
they have some really interesting
diamonds that they found you know so so
I think you can think of it as kind of a
two-stage process one is as this
transparency and as the data comes out a
lot of organizations are really simply
just trying to make it legible and you
know huge kudos to sunlight just
absolute leaders in that area and the
point is that once it's legible you get
a second generation of people who are
actually doing stuff with it and
potentially becoming more engaged and
that's kind of more the work that we've
been doing at the Civic Media Center is
to say assuming data now what are the
different models for engagement and
we're finding that there are radically
different models for social change that
are just becoming available with some of
these tools
we put it blaring the line between
public and private action I think that's
definitely true that that's happening
and that's why agencies that are writing
social media policies like DoD just just
released theirs today why that's so hard
for them because you know there's a very
limited sense in which you know career
employees might have a public voice and
suddenly it's one that could make CNN in
two hours at any time so that's been
difficult for them to think through and
that that's also the reason that it's so
offensive to all of us when the
government gets it wrong when they enter
in a public-private partnership that's
exclusive like for example when when Gao
decided to digitize these extremely
valuable documents legislative histories
that they had and they paid a private
company to do it in a way that the
public would never get access to it and
they had to continue to buy a
subscription to that company to get
access to their own records so that was
nothing but a subsidy to that company
and the public got no benefit at all
from digitizing all these public records
so to me that the idea of a
public/private partnership or our rules
as people or as or as associations and
organizations is suddenly very different
than it was in a way that has a lot of
opportunity but also some complex
complex risks okay we've been listening
to some of the upside some of the
downside some of the questions that are
in the group I'd like our panelists to
give some parting thoughts now
particularly ideas of priorities for
what we should be doing with this
situation and these ideas next Christmas
well I guess I would just say that you
know we had a little bit more time to
spend with Eugene and his team during
the day and peppered them with questions
and I think you know they've done a
great job of thinking within the Mandate
of FCC what's going to be necessary to
try to get this plan to work but I think
that it's really critical that the
effort doesn't stop with them and that
the pressure on the government doesn't
stop and and you know I think that what
we've seen is that broadband could be an
incredibly enabling thing or it could
just be a rehearsal of the worst aspects
of broadcast media as they kind of
coalesced in the 50s and 60s
so let's just let's get on it no sleep
for any of you I just like to quote
Craig Newmark of Craigslist when he says
I welcome my nerd overlords we're at a
time of serious revolution and it's not
just technology if we go out in the
streets and knock on our neighbor's
doors and meet them face to face that
email and petition that you create later
will actually you know be a lot easier
to send and and mobilize your street
just start with your street and I
encourage you all to go meet as I've
heard one police one member of your City
Council and then a teacher and someone
else on your block they don't know so
that is the non-technical path that we
can take and then the other thing is
just not to fear technology because in
most cases we are intending to do no
harm or very little harm but we do want
to embrace what it can do and it can
make government more efficient more open
and in turn make citizens more
participatory in their civic processes
it's familiar to me that you you talk
about transparency and participation but
then end up focusing on transparency and
that's because it's much easier to do
that it's much easier to say well
there's this thing that might have all
these good effects but well let's at
least figure out what we need in order
to make that possible I reminds me of
turning 16 and learning to drive and
being so excited and then just driving
around at night because I was so excited
to be able to drive it and necessarily
have somewhere to go so I think we all
have to think we all had some thinking
to do about about what it is we want to
do with these tools and the potentials
enormous enormous and it's gonna there's
no right answers it's going to be an act
of creation and if you have ideas like
the questioner before that I think right
now is a great time to submit them every
every 23 of the agencies have slash open
pages and they need to come up with
pilot plans for participation so if you
all have ideas for that they would they
would love to I met with a lot of people
at agencies they would love to be
validated by your ideas about what
they're thinking through yeah also to
address that last comment about whether
transparency
enables participation I think one of the
things that transparency does is it
gives you a face on the other side and
when you realize there's a human there
and it's a human talking to a human you
end up with a much more civil discussion
and I think that's something really
exciting and wonderful my closing
thoughts about all this would be that
the way technology is working right now
it gives us the opportunity to iterate
an experiment and fail small so I think
that's that's something to keep in mind
especially when you're talking about
government spending and not spending 80
million dollars on on making it to other
data cup website and then to impart some
advice that I read on some personal
productivity self-help blog the other
day you take the hardest thing on your
to-do list and just spend five minutes
doing it first and I think that's a nice
way to think about getting involved with
your community and being engaged in a
civic way so I encourage you all to just
start start small I'll do the same one
of the fun things about being a
moderators you get to say a few things
at the end but in listening to this I'd
really just like to underline what's
what's happened down on the other side
of the table Chris and Laura sort of
focused on something that I think is
likely very central to this whole thing
which is as you look at how technology
has been applied in the world and
certainly in governments the there's a
little hard part in getting the
technology right but the hard part is
getting the politics so you can act on
it and the political strategy that takes
these ideas from where they are now to
where they'll really be effective is
going to be critical and so that's idea
number one idea number two I would argue
is really sort of picking up a bit from
John and Nick as well in many ways
engagement in participation is easier
now because the barrier is lower we can
do things in little bits of time that
used to require huge amounts of time
what I have not seen yet and what I
think our experiments need to go on and
some of our analysis needs to go on is
you know let's take ideas like the big
ones of Education and Health and Safety
and
in world and small business all
emphasized in the FCC plans but let us
think about engagement in small pieces
is there a taxonomy of ways we can build
sustainable public support by asking
people for a little bit and this
technology makes it so convenient for
people to give you a little bit for
campaigns that was a little bit of money
at first and then it was a little bit of
these other things and so the political
world has sort of learned a bit about
how to entice people into engagement a
little bit at a time but our world of
governance and Community Action opened
up now by broadband we've got to think
those things through and I hope we do
and I hope we're successful and thank
you folks very much Thank You panel
[Applause]